how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we do have some excellent
MCU news we have some one division news
today some Falcon and the Winter Soldier
news and some shang-chi and the legend
of the ten rings news today it seems
like things are starting to pick up a
little bit after Marvel Studios had to
postpone and put on hold a lot of their
current projects including all their
Disney Plus shows and movies that are
coming to phase four now these projects
being put on hold of course shifted
Marvel's released scheduled for phase
four but it seems like things are slowly
starting to come back and as that
happens we get more and more information
about the shows and movies that we've
been waiting for so we'll break down to
this news in this video but first
congratulations to youtube user Alex Rey
as one to two 7:06 for being the winner
of the Wolverine
Funko pop giveaway email me in the email
that's in my about Me section and we'll
get you your Funko pop and for this
week's giveaway we're giving away a
Black Panther Funko pop all you have to
do to enter to win is subscribe to my
channel like this video and leave a
comment down below so to start off the
phase 4 news we have some great news
about the one division series this is
quite possibly one of the most
anticipated projects coming in phase
four out of all the shows and all of the
movies and today we got a report from
Charles Murphy that should put a smile
on everybody's faces he shared a part of
a resume for somebody who is working on
the one division series and on this we
can see it says one division Episode one
zero nine role indie stunts but the big
important part here is to pay attention
to where it says Episode one zero nine
typically how they do this is they state
the season first and then the episode
number so it's Season one Episode nine
meaning one division is going to have
nine episodes in the first season this
is three more episodes than we thought
we were going to get everybody assumed
that it was going to be six episodes but
it's actually going to be quite long
especially if you consider the fact that
each episode is probably going to be an
hour long and this implies what we've
all been expecting that the wann
division series is going to have a
serious impact on the Marvel Cinematic
Universe moving forward and that could
possibly be the reason why it has so
many episodes and thanks to an update on
Falcon
in the winter soldier from anthony
mackie the Falcon himself we have a
little bit of insight on how these shows
are going to feel in an interview with
variety anthony mackie said this we're
shooting it exactly like a movie
everybody who had worked on TV before
was like I've never worked on a TV show
like this the way in which we were
shooting it feels exactly like we were
shooting the movie cut up into the show
so instead of a two hour movie a six or
eight hour movie so for those of you who
are expecting just a normal TV show that
is not what we're going to be getting
instead we're going to be getting a six
to eight hour movie basically cut up the
filming is going to be like a movie
everything is going to feel like an
actual movie which is great news because
we can assume that Marvel is going to
shoot every single Disney Plus show they
have coming out exactly the same way and
this is why all of the shows are going
to connect to the MCU because they
basically are movies they're basically
just really long movies and also in the
interview he states that they hope to go
back to filming very soon but it also
looks like one project for Marvel
Studios could have already gone back to
work and that is shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings a couple of
reddit users posted online a few set
photos of a new set being built in
Sydney Australia for shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings and according to
these reddit users these were taking a
few weeks ago which means that Marvel
Studios has been back working on the
production of shang-chi and the legend
of the ten rings for about three weeks
now we know that of course Marvel is
going to be taking precautions on
everything that they do coming back to
filming again but it looks like
shengqi's production has resumed and it
looks like the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier wonda vision and the Hawkeye
series are going to follow not too long
after so great news things are kind of
slowly starting to come back from Marvel
Studios which means that we shouldn't
have that many more delays and hopefully
we don't because I'm ready to see these
six to nine hour movies in the form of a
Disney Plus show so let me know what you
think about this news in the comments
down below are you excited to see these
Disney plush shows and which one are you
most excited to see let me know what you
think in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up-to-date on
everything or relating to the MCU for
live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof